he is the mvp reigning mvp of the
national football league getting set to
take on the lions on monday night
football to wrap up week number two he
is none other than aaron rodgers how are
you aaron
hey good thanks for having me on thanks
for being on here how's everything with
you these days everything going all
right uh
other than the you know
this point in week one i think it's been
really good excellent fantastic because
you know i've been i've been waiting to
talk to you for some time i've been
waiting to talk to you for some time
it's been too long it's been a few
months since we have talked and uh a lot
has gone on with you i don't know if
you're aware of that aaron uh no no not
really i mean there's no game of thrones
to talk about there's no gamer so what
are you watching these days then
what are you watching i'm anxiously
awaiting season three of the uh
afterlife okay i'm enjoying the heck out
of ted lasso how great is that right and
that's amazing it's spectacular um and
as is normal during camp training camp
it's probably the most tennis ever watch
i enjoy the night time watching the us
open and just finished up but uh
even without the williams sisters and
fed and rafa it was uh it was a good
tournament well i got to tell you emma
radicano her story is one of my favorite
sports stories in the history of sports
stories that you go from it's amazing
incredible it did you go from you know
hey i'm just happy to be here i'm going
to try to qualify for the us open and
then win it at age 18. that is
all kinds of awesome the whole story and
and i don't think she lost a set did she
no she did not
the last the last time she had lost a
set i think was uh at at an event in
like july that's about it and then she
showed up and she qualified and she made
it and it's just i i'll be honest man i
i told my kids like this is the power of
belief in yourself like this is the true
story power of belief in yourself
fact yeah and let's not overlook her
opponent either i mean i think she was
what 19 19 i know yeah
right and barely in the top 100 and made
it and beat i think what three major
winners on the way to finals or
something unbelievable and then the just
the way they comported themselves uh
that's pretty cool so that's what you
were watching when you were just done
watching practicing getting ready for
yourself some time i enjoyed watching
right i mean i like the early rounds too
there's a lot of you know unknowns and
up and comers much like those two
teenage girls right fun to watch and ted
lasso is so much fun too uh because of
how positive it is
and the positivity of it um and the
belief you know the believe sign but roy
kent is my favorite character in that
entire series
he's amazing we that's what we need on
on football sports tacos
that's exactly what we need
that would be
roy kent just basically calling bs on
everybody you know but there there are
some shows on sports tv that come pretty
damn close
yes they don't have a roy ken i think i
could be the roy can't i don't think
anybody would
would want me to but i think i think
there's a few of us that could that
could do that how was jeopardy how was
that how was the blast absolute blast i
had
i had so much fun i mean just being
around that environment and being on
stage that alex
shined on for
uh more than three decades more than
three and a half decades uh
getting to know the crew was just so fun
i mean the
makeup ladies the hair lady the
uh stylist
all the people on the floor i mean it
was
it was a dream i mean it was surreal
from the first moment i stepped on until
uh you know kind of taking my bowels as
i left i was just in total gratitude to
be there and
blown away and really wanted to do a
good job i feel like i represented
myself and alex
well and
and just had a lot of fun doing it
thankful for that opportunity and it's a
hell of an opportunity as you know and
you know the the game play of it hosting
it is not easy to do and then just being
you know part of a broadcast team is
just not easy to just get just slip
right into and then you get stuff
snapped off at you like that guy who who
responded to an answer like he was cliff
on cheers right where he just blew the
answer and he just basically made a a
comment about the nfc championship game
that was a nice curveball snapchat
yeah my first episode too that was that
come on it was that was your first one
he snapped my first yeah my first real
episode
it was uh it was pretty amazing and the
best part is you could kind of see
during the 30 seconds
uh of final jeopardy when the classic
music is playing
uh my screen goes to their boards so i
can see what they're writing so i
started to see the beginning of his
answer before i went
to take my mark and get ready for the
reveal and i could tell it was going in
that direction
i actually didn't i didn't want to see
any more because i wanted to have a
natural reaction i want to plan when i
but i was thinking he was probably going
to go in that direction so once i
started saying seeing him write
something i was like okay i got gotta
get to my spot so i can have just a real
authentic reaction to whatever he put
down because i know it's gonna be some
sort of joke about something packers
fans are everywhere are they not aaron
rodgers they're absolutely everywhere
all right so let's just get into a
couple a couple questions that i i want
to ask you because man i was wondering i
don't know if you're aware
everyone was talking about you literally
for every day um from pretty much um
april all the way through to the day
that you did show up uh in green bay was
there a time where it was true when all
the reporting that you were definitely
done playing in green bay you thought in
your head i am done i am not going back
there because that's the way it was
described for a while aaron no i mean i
think that's definitely an exaggeration
i think there were there were many
things i was
hoping were gonna adjust moving forward
but i i never
uh closed the door on returning
completely just like i didn't close the
door on retiring i think i wanted to
leave all options open i wanted to
handle things
uh in private now obviously because of
you know who i am and
and the nature of our relationship
i knew it couldn't be completely quiet
there were uh
there were other factors involved and
and uh
you know people with agendas uh involved
as well so i knew but i just didn't want
to i don't want to comment publicly
because i didn't want to trash the team
uh that i played for for 16 years i have
so much love and affection for this area
and so many members of the organization
i just you know i just felt like that
was the right thing to do now that
probably bothered some people because
people thought maybe i could have shut
things down if i just said something and
i thought many times about doing that
but
every time i thought maybe this is the
right time it just seemed felt
intuitively
um
that it was too much emotion wrapped up
in it and it wasn't it wasn't the right
time and i needed to wait
and i feel like uh it was the right
decision ultimately
and you know i was excited to be back
and excited to be back with the guys
and also resolute about
you know wanting to be a part of change
going forward and wanting things to be
different what is the change that you
received that allowed you to say okay
let's do this what was that well
i mean i think there was
there's nothing
necessary that can be stamped on a piece
of paper it's more
uh
trust
you know trust is a
trust and hope can be beautiful things
they can also lead to despair and and
frustration as well but i i tend to to
be a little more altruistic and
optimistic on on those two things and
it's trusting and hoping that things uh
can improve and and we can all grow
together i don't i feel like i wanted to
make that clear as well that i wasn't at
all a victim ever in this in the
circumstance you know i'm fortunate to
have played for so long and been paid
so well for so long
i just want to be a part of things you
know continuing to grow and get better
in my time here and it's just trusting
that
we can all grow and and
communicate better and do things
uh in ways that can continue to
find ways to honor our current players
former players and
and restore dignity to those guys who
deserve it and so have you aaron rodgers
here in the mercedes-benz vans uh phone
line on the rich eisen show have you
seen something already
has there been a change already that you
can maybe
point to in a concrete way that that
okay this is what i was talking about
this is why i wanted to
have my say with the front office in a
certain manner
yeah i mean the communication has
definitely been better okay
and and that was
from kind of the first day i got back uh
the communication
i think has been a lot better uh
being involved in conversations that
directly affect my job that was
basically what i was saying i wanted
i wanted things to to change in that in
that manner and
i feel like i've been a part of a lot of
conversation to directly impact my job
so
uh
starting off uh starting off the right
way okay do you have a conversation with
tom brady at all on this subject matter
since i guess he's kind of the
the standard bearer of you know all-time
great long time with a team figuring out
what what needs to be done for him
personally as well with the team that
maybe he's thinking about or with
sticking with did you have maybe even at
any point uh off camera off mike in
montana which was beautiful by the way
and by the way congratulations on
sticking the
sticking it to uh phil my gosh when he's
just chirping at you but did you have
any conversations with with another 12
on the subject matter at any point in
time
i mean we've we definitely had
conversations uh before and after we
were mic'd up
um
you know tom and i have been friends for
a long time and and enjoy every time we
get a chance to to catch up
um
but look i i think i know pretty much
what went on
you know with him down there
uh
different situation you know i've been
here for 16 years and he was going to a
new team
obviously a lot of the things that he
was asking for and wanted he got you
know
whether it was antonio or gronk or
whatnot but um different situation and
this is uh you know obviously very
personal to me so um i did have some
conversations with a number of uh close
friends and confidants about this uh
situation and those definitely helped
uh help me
with the right perspective moving
forward and then monday night are you
gonna just i mean where where are you on
this i mean last time you were on and uh
last year um or two times ago when you
were on last year you said you were at
peace with yourself are you gonna when
you step out monday night lions lambeau
field uh look around like soak it in
like this may be one of the last times
you do it i mean how are you going about
your business
on
definitely yeah definitely soaking in
uh not thinking about that this could be
my last home monday night game or any of
those things
um
but definitely we'll soak it in just we
haven't had fans really you know other
than small
splattering last year in playoffs
so it'll be nice to to be back home and
hear that crowd noise and
in a game that matters i'm gonna have
football good chance to respond after a
rough first week so
that's what i will take in but there's
nothing like that first kind of run out
on the field and
uh pregame and then the first time we
have the ball on offense it's just
you know that you jog on the field you
hear the roar the crowds start to come
up and it just
i mean your whole body starts tingling
the hairs on your arm or standing up and
it's it's some it's something special
you just can't replicate that no you
can't it's a cathedral man it's a
cathedral and and there's so many fans
that thought honestly that you
like you ca it's funny i mean i mean
it's not funny but i mean it's kind of
crazy i've been saying on nfl network
that you're back even though you never
left you know and and there may be a lot
of fans who thought that that you're
going to hear from them
monday night that you're going to hear
it that they thought that they would
never see you come out of that tunnel in
that uniform again
you know well and yeah and i i i look
forward to feeling that there's been
some amazing moments over the years
uh
jogging on and off that field that will
always you know stick with me and i hope
we got a couple more
a couple more this season all right
aaron rodgers i greatly appreciate it um
i'd love to talk to you throughout the
season i always appreciate our chats um
and uh you know whenever you do decide
to hang it up whatever you want to do
i hope it is being the roy kent of
sports television my god i hope that's
your choice you know what it when it
comes down to it
yeah that would be fun man
and in the meantime you know aaron you
know i'll invite you uh you know do you
want to do a once a week thing maybe
tuesdays on this show aaron what do you
want to do go everywhere
let me see you know i mean i don't know
what you're doing on tuesdays uh but if
you want to just every every week you
know call in you could just sit wherever
you want brick wall behind you
i'm just throwing that out there um you
know uh and see chop it up just throw it
out there i'll get back to you i'll
circle back with you let me know let me
know okay you take care of yourself
aaron rodgers you're the best all right
richard thank you man that's aaron
rodgers right here monday night football
taking on the detroit lions
end week two
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here